just as a small
tangent your master's thesis is also
fascinating um maybe
we could talk about it for just a little
bit it's uh titled the influence of a
star's evolution on this planetary
system
so this interplay between a star and a
planet
is there something interesting you could
say about what you've learned about this
this journey that star takes
and the planets around it well when i
was younger and i was told what would
happen
ultimately to the earth as the sun
expands towards a red giant and you know
mercury would just like
fall in and then you know venus
fall in and the sun doesn't care and it
just seemed
so i felt so small
i felt like the earth and everything on
it it's just
the universe doesn't care even our sun
doesn't care
and i think i felt like our son should
feel some sort of responsibility
and it just felt like such a violent and
neglectful parent
it's like a parent eating its own
children it's horrible it's just a
horrible notion but it made me think
what if this there's some sort of
generation and so
at the time when i was doing my masters
there was a notion of the white dwarf
cemetery which is this idea that
when stars become white dwarfs that
death is so horrible
that planets potentially habitable
planets that could have been habitable
before
they're now gone there's no there's no
chance for life
but then i thought what if life returns
you know now it's a white dwarf it's
calmed down it's not going to go
anywhere white dwarfs are very stable
across like universal time scales and so
could you
have planets around a white dwarf that
could themselves
get life again you know life doesn't
care
and so my work was basically killing
dozens of planets thousands of times i
just ran
thousands and thousands of end body
simulations well you simulated this yeah
so i simulated the star
wow growing and just eating all these
planets up and just
absolute chaos um the orbits of the
planets would change as the
star loses mass so you would have like
jupiter planet like planets just
crashing into the other planets throwing
them into the sun
early it was terrifying to watch these
simulations
it was absolute carnage
but if you run thousands of these
simulations
some systems find new balance ways of
staying
alive some systems
post star death find stable orbits again
for billions of years more than enough
for life to originate again
and so that was my idea during that time
that thesis was trying to explore
this notion of life coming back
and this idea of the universe doesn't
care if you're here or not
and it will go about its business you
know andromeda will crash into us and
doesn't care no one cares if you're
alive in the universe and so
letting go of that preciousness of life
i found very useful at that stage in my
career
and instead i just thought what if if
life is inevitable
it doesn't matter that it came by four
billion years ago it can start again
four billion years later
and maybe that is nice maybe that's
where hope lies the
phoenix rising everywhere plan is being
destroyed and created
and we're here now and others will be
more or less here-ish billions of years
later so accepting the cycle of death
and life and
oh yeah i'm not taking it personally not
taking it personally
the son doesn't owe us anything you're
not a bad parent it's not a parent at
all
yeah i was looking at the work of
freeman dyson and
seeing how it how this universe
eventually will just be a bunch of
supermassive black holes
before they also evacuate tiny black
holes too
yeah absolutely quiet everyone all the
black holes a little too far away from
one another
to even interact until it's just silence
forever but until then
many many cycles of death and
destruction and rebirth
and rebirth
you